welche fluggäste werden getestet und
nach welchen regeln läuft das ab hallo
vom frankfurter flughafen
also grundlegend gibt es hier zwei
verschiedene test centern jetzt einmal
das wo die leute hingehen können die
erst noch fliegen wollen
das bezahlen die auch für ihren test und
sie kriegen dann je nach preis des tests
auch ihr ergebnis innerhalb von drei
oder sechs stunden und das ist dann auch
zertifiziert und sie können ihren flug
nehmen
dort gehen auch die leute hin die
einfach sich nur so testen lassen wollen
wie eigentlich gar nicht auf einer reise
waren die einfach wissen wollen ob sie
erkrankt sind
dann gibt es jetzt ganz neu seit gestern
auch ein testcenter des bak
dann gehen die leute hin die aus
risikogebieten zurückgekehrt sind und
können sich dort testen lassen und zwar
kostenlos
wir haben es eben in den bildern gesehen
es ist ja ganz schön was los wie
erklärst du dir den ansturm
ja auf jeden fall machen sich die leute
ganz große sorgen jemanden anzustecken
wenn sie irgendwo waren wo ganz viele
leute waren wie zum beispiel sich nicht
unbedingt an die regeln gehalten haben
ich habe jemals einer familie gesprochen
die waren in den niederlanden
da haben wohl ganz viele leute keine
masken getragen unter anderem auf die
deutschen die dort im vorlauf waren dann
gab es da einen regional nahen ausbruch
und die familie ist sehr besorgt dass
sie sich vielleicht auch infiziert haben
könnten die kommen dann extra hier an
den flughafen gefahren und lassen sich
hier testen obwohl sie mit dem auto im
urlaub waren und gar nicht jetzt erst
hier angekommen sind
wir gehen denn die reiserückkehrer mit
diesem angebot um nehmen sie das dankbar
an oder sind sie auch genervt also die
meisten die sind sehr froh darüber dass
es diese möglichkeit gibt auch sich
jetzt kostenlos testen zu lassen
allerdings sieht auch bei angegangen
dass sie gereizt und genervt sind das
überhaupt dieses ganze hin und her auch
zwischen den schlangen sehen finden die
situation teilweise als sehr
unübersichtlich
also die fragen sich wird nicht dann
hierdurch hier sind die mitarbeiter der
verschiedenen anbieter jetzt hier also
fonds entschieden die große firma die
das hier
aber auch vom drk obwohl es eine
kollaboration ist werden dann aber ein
bisschen hin- und hergeschickt sind
verwirrt wissen teilweise nicht dass sie
sich eigentlich hätten online
registrieren sollen machen das dann mit
den mitarbeitern stellen sich dann an
die stange ist teilweise 200 meter lang
ging dann gesagt dass die fast eine
stunde warten müssen
teilweise geht schneller wenn sie glück
haben aber man sieht die sind das sind
strapazen wenn man dann auch noch einen
langen flug hinter sich hat etwa aus
dubai zum beispiel dann ist es sehr
anstrengend es ist sehr heiss auch hier
in diesem durchgang und das ist
natürlich kein spaß also die leute haben
schon triftige gründe und sorgen sich
hier das anzutun wenn sie jetzt sich
freiwillig stand hier testen lassen
dennoch kommen ja auch die sprache es an
menschen die gar nicht im urlaub waren
und wollen sich testen lassen was muss
man denn alles vorlegen um sich testen
zu lassen
ja also auf jeden fall in sachen kommune
geht natürlich nichts ohne seine daten
zu hinterlassen auf jeden fall muss man
einen personalausweis dabei haben
natürlich wenn man jetzt den
kostenpflichtigen test macht weil man
irgendwohin fliegen will muss man auf
jeden fall auch zahlen also eine
kreditkarte eine flugnummer ist nicht
einmal nötig weil diese risikogebiet
teste sie stehen auch für jene leute zur
verfügung die nicht mit einem flug
angekommen sind man kann sich also auch
als risikogebiet rückkehrer der offenen
landweg bekommen ist zum beispiel testen
lassen man muss das also nicht unbedingt
mit einem flug nachweisen
das heißt da geht man auch einfach seine
daten an und erklärt die situation dann
kann man diesen fest auf wahrnehmen was
ist denn wenn ich bereits vor drei tagen
aus dem urlaub zurückgekehrt bin darf
dann auch kommen und mich testen zu
lassen
ja das geht auch also das maximum wurde
auf 72 stunden festgelegt also es ist
auf jeden fall jetzt was man aber hier
auch immer wieder holt also man sieht
das ist hier teilweise wirklich an der
jaaa und der grenze der überlastung
einfach es sind unglaublich viele leute
die hier in diesem durchgang stehen es
ist stickig heiß und morgen soll dann
noch einmal von der politik noch mal
eruiert werden wer eigentlich jetzt
diese kostenlosen tests
machen darf weil halt das wirklich hier
schon so ausgelastet ist dass man da
noch einmal darüber reden muss ob das so
weitergehen kann weil es kommen immer
mehr leute alle wollen einen test machen
und ob das die richtige der richtige weg
ist das so an den flughäfen anzubieten
das dann leute von überall her kommen um
auch diese grad ist es zwar zu nehmen ob
es so weitergehen kann das muss die
politik auf jeden fall nochmal
voraussichtlich morgen auf besprechen